so my guest tonight is a very funny
actor who played Gabe on the office and
now you can check him out on the new HBO
show Silicon Valley
please welcome everybody my friend Zach
wood Zach
Zach hey I'm so glad you're here this is
a real trip for me Zach and I were
friends in New York yeah and you taught
my improv class at UCB
yes what yeah right I was talking to uh
new producers I'm saying I wish that you
had been in some way a difficult or
terrible student but you were just an
amazing improviser it doesn't make for
good stories it's just no it does give
it a try I mean Pete just shattered the
backboard everything but you that was in
New York right my producers I'm not
going to make it seem like we didn't do
research they told me I didn't know this
you had a weird way to get to New York
well I started doing improv when I was a
16 I would take the train I lived in
Pennsylvania in like a little suburb in
Pennsylvania and I would take the train
into New York to do classes and shows
that Upright Citizens Brigade and I
liked I didn't tell any when I went to
school with because I liked having like
a secret life in New York some kids
build like a shed in the woods and
you're like she's mine you were going
into Manhattan and studying I I had a
shed to where I started taking improv
classes I wanted to be a jazz musician
very badly and um okay just do that I
mean I wanted I wanted the full
experience I wanted to be in New York
and I want to be a jazz musician and I
would play trumpet
I had like memorized the autobiography
of Miles Davis and lived quiet as a
personal Bible you memorize it
parts of it not the whole thing I'd wear
a fedora
but like no other jazz close just a
fedora and then normal like
fourteen-year-old boy clothes if you
like a fedora and then like a picture of
like a picture and it say like dude
Bugle Boy shorts and this guy that's
heroin yeah